welcome back to understanding Quantum information and computation my name is John matus and I'm the technical director for education at IBM
Quantum this is the 12th lesson in the series and it's the last lesson in the third unit which is on the general
formulation of quantum information this lesson is centered around a fundamental notion in Quantum information which is that of a
purification of a Quantum State a purification of a Quantum State represented by some density Matrix is a
pure state of a larger compound system that leaves us with the original state when the rest of the compound system is
discarded or traced out every density Matrix has a purification and we can learn a lot
about Quantum States and about Quantum information in general by studying purifications at an intuitive level
Quantum State vectors which represent pure states are simpler mathematical objects than density matrices and by thinking about
purifications of States we're able toew arbitrary Quantum states of systems as being just parts of something larger but
simpler we'll also talk about the Fidelity between two Quantum states which is a value that quantifies their
similarity or overlap and it's often used as a way of measuring how good a particular state is as compared with
some ideal state in particular we'll discuss the definition of fidelity along with some of its basic properties and we'll see
how Fidelity connects with purifications here's an overview of the lesson we'll start with purifications including the
definition and a simple proof of their existence which tells us how to find one if we need one then we'll discuss something known
as the Schmid decomposition of a Quantum State Vector of two systems and we'll see how Schmid decompositions relate to
purifications then we'll discuss a critically important relationship between any two purifications of the same state which is known as the unitary
equivalence of purifications and finally we'll go through a few examples we then turn to Fidelity
including its definition and some of its basic properties we'll talk about the gentle measurement Lemma which is a very
handy fact that ties Fidelity back to measurements and finally to conclude the lesson we'll turn toan's theorem which
establishes a fundamental connection between Fidelity and purifications let's start with the
definition of a purification a purification of a state which assume is represented by a density
Matrix is a pure state of a larger compound system that leaves the original state that we started with when the rest
of the compound system is traced out we can express this more precisely in mathematical terms as
follows if we have a system X that's in some State row meaning that row is a density Matrix representing a state of X
and S is a Quantum State Vector of a pair of systems XY such that tracing out y from the pure State C side bro plus I
leaves us with row then we say that s is a purification of row naturally the names don't matter we
can name our systems and our states whatever we want and The Ordering of the systems also doesn't matter for example
if the system y was on the left rather than on the right but everything else was the same we'd still refer to SAI as being a purification of row but we'll
mainly stick to this setup for the remainder of the lesson just for the sake of Simplicity and the first thing to say
about definition is that purifications always exist for every density Matrix row and to be more precise every density
Matrix row has a purification like the definition describes provided that the system y is at least as large as X which
is to say that y has at least as many classical States as X the notion of a purification and the
fact that purifications always exist turns out to be critically important and it's also part of what makes Quantum information beautiful and hopefully I'll
be able to convince of that fact by the end of the lesson now let's prove that every density metrix has a purification and in
the process we'll see how we can get our hands on a purification when we need one just like we had in the definition
of a purification let's suppose that X is a system and row is a density Matrix that represents a state of
X now consider any expression of row as a convex combination of pure States as we have written on the screen in words
for some choice of of a positive integer n we have a probability Vector p 0 through PN minus1 as well as Quantum
State vectors 5 0 through 5 nus one and by averaging the corresponding pure States weighted by the probabilities we
obtain Row for instance we could use the spectral theorem to obtain an expression of row like this and if we did that we
could take n to be the number of classical states of X in fact we could take n to be the rank of row which is
equal to the number of non-zero won values of row counting each one a number of times equal to its multiplicity and
that's never larger than the number of classical states of X but it could be smaller on the other hand this doesn't
have to be a spectral decomposition of row and we don't need these Quantum State vectors to be orthogonal for instance any expression of row like this
is fine and here's a purification of row the sum ranges over the same values as
in our expression of row and inside of the sum we take the square roots of the probabilities multiplied to F A tensored
with k a here by the way we're assuming that 0 through n minus one are classical states of the second system y so it
makes sense that s is a Quantum State Vector of the pair XY like in the definition it's not actually important
here that we use standard basis states of Y in this expression you could substitute any orthonormal collection of
states in place of K 0 through Kat n minus one if you wanted to and now we can check that this is indeed
a purification by Computing the partial Trace over y here's an expression of the state that we get by performing the partial trace
the trace of k a bra B is either one or zero depending upon whether or not a is equal to B and so the expression
simplifies to our original expression of row and it's a simple as that so it's very easy to get our hands on a
purification as long as we have enough classical states of Y or alternatively a large enough orthonormal set to use in
place of the standard Bas of States cat 0 through cat n minus one and by the way if the number of
classical states of Y is smaller than the rank of row then there won't be a purification and I'll leave that for you
to ponder if you choose to do that here's an example let's consider
the density Matrix that we saw several times in the lesson on density matrices here we have an expression of this
density Matrix as a convex combination of pure States it's not a spectral decomposition but we don't
care and with almost no effort at all we can write down a purification of the state by following the
recipe that's not the only purification of this density Matrix purifications aren't unique but that's okay the